according to the Daily Beast today first
daughter Ivanka Trump secretly met with
Planned Parenthood president Cecile
Richards in January the story does not
make clear whether the meeting took
place before or after Trump's
inauguration but Ivanka is Trump's most
trusted advisor along with her husband
Jared Kushner and she's a moving force
behind much of the action in his
administration according to The Daily
Beast quote the purpose of the meeting
from Cecile's point of view was to make
sure that a vodka fully understood what
Planned Parenthood does how it is funded
and why it would be a terrible idea for
Planned Parenthood to be removed from
being able to see Medicaid patients
heads on Logans a executive vice
president of the planned parenthood
federation of america the main thing
that Cecile was doing was explaining
that the money doesn't actually go to
abortions we get reimbursed the same way
a hospital does we were clearing up
misinformation about how this works
unquote Richards now says that Ivanka is
part of the problem since she hasn't
openly sounded off on her father's
opposition to funding Planned Parenthood
according to Richard's quote anyone who
works in this White House is responsible
for addressing why women are in the
crosshairs of basically every single
policy we've seen in this administration
it's worth noting me just yesterday
Ivanka told Gayle King on CBS this
morning that she sounds off against her
father's policies all the time behind
closed doors quote I would say not to
conflate lack of public announcement
with silence she explained so is Ivanka
still something for Planned Parenthood
behind closed doors and Trump has made
clear he's willing to use Planned
Parenthood as a cudgel to motivate
Republicans but he also spent months
talking about all the non abortion great
work Planned Parenthood does which
accounts for my nude fraction of the
revenue Trump may have shifted his
position for politics but ivanka
probably hasn't she's a career leftist
on a variety of issues from climate
change to abortion to same-sex marriage
her speech at the Republican National
Convention was an ode to
government-sponsored child care as
Stephen Miller of heat Street pointed
out quote Ivanka has donated thousands
of dollars to prominent Democratic
candidates including Harry Reid andrew
Cuomo Eleanor Holmes Norton Kirsten
Gillibrand Gavin Newsom Chuck Schumer
Cory Booker Eliot Spitzer Hillary
Clinton's Senate and 2008 presidential
campaign and just recently to New
Democrats star senator Kamala Harris in
the interest of fairness she did donate
to mccain in romney 2012 but according
to sources contributions to republicans
make up less than ten percent of her
overall donations Ivanka was not even
able to vote for her father in the GOP
primary as she did not switch her party
affiliation by the deadline Ivanka is
the person closest to Trump's heart in
this administration an administration
filled with people
with little political background that
who compete to demonstrate that a
loyalty to the president Ivanka will not
be trumped in this regard that means she
may have her father's ear even on issues
upon which they disagree and that is not
a good thing I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show so today's an extremely
busy news day we're going to get to get
to nunez devon nuñez has now been
refused he's recused himself from the
russia investigation on the House
Intelligence Committee will tell you
what that means Steve benen is out at
the National Security Council so a lot
of turmoil happening inside the
Republican caucus plus president Trump
is making open overtures now to the left
which is not a good thing but before we
get there we have to say and we should
say obviously thank you to our
advertisers over at lift so if you are
looking for a ride sharing company
that's going to make sure that you're
safe and you ride in a clean car the
driver isn't a creeper lift is the place
for you i know because i use lift my
wife uses left my wife comes home very
late at night from the from her job in
residency she's that should doctor and
and sometimes very late at night and
she's very tired and I don't want her
driving when she's super tired so she
takes lift my wife is a young attractive
woman and the only people I trust to
take her home the only people she trusts
to take her home are the folks over at
lift safety is their number one priority
every single driver is fully vetted
through a 10 point safety standard
including third-party criminal and DMV
background checks and every car on the
road has to pass a 19-point vehicle
inspection so you're not going to get
somebody pulling up in a clunker that
looks like it is directly out of Escape
from New York so it is a great company
you can check them out over at lift and
when you download the app make sure that
any payment section use the promo code
Shapiro and that will give you three
free rides up to ten dollars each for
new customers up to thirty dollar value
when you enter that promo code Shapiro
so make sure you download it and you
enter that promo code Shapiro you
download the free lift app and for that
promo code my last name in the payment
section promo code Shapiro and make sure
you use that promo code not only to get
the three free rides up to ten dollars
each for new customers but also so that
they know that we sent you okay so the
big news of the day is that Devan Nunez
who's or Devin Nunes I guess it's
pronounced there's been a big debate in
political circles how do you pronounce
this guy's last name so Nunes i think is
how to actually pronounced Devin
Newton's who is the chair of the house
and tell
committee he announced on Thursday he
has recused himself from the committee's
investigation into Russia's alleged
meddling in the 2016 election now this
poses a problem for the Trump
administration because the Trump
administration basically funneled all of
the information about Susan Rice
unmasking members of the Trump team and
the term transition team they funnels
all that to Nunes by bringing him to the
White House and then he didn't update
his house intelligence committee friends
and foes and then he went back to the
White House to update Trump so it looked
like noone's is working for Trump that
was really what this came down to the
reason that he is is recusing himself is
because the house ethics committee has
now put him under investigation now to
be clear they're not investigating him
because they're saying he's a tool of
the White House they're investigating
him because anytime somebody allegedly
leaked classified information they are
they they are investigated by law Nunes
has explained in a statement that he is
is not he's not recusing himself cause
he did anything wrong he says several
left-wing activist groups have filed
accusations against me with the Office
of Congressional effects the charges are
entirely false and politically motivated
on are being leveled just as the
American people are beginning to learn
the truth about the improper unmasking
of the identities of US citizens and
other abuses of power despite the
baseless pneus of the charges I believe
it is in the best interest of the House
Intelligence Committee and the Congress
for me to have Representative Mike
Conway with assistant from
representatives trey Gowdy and Tom
Rooney temporarily take charge of
committees Russia investigation while
the house ethics committee looks into
the matter I will continue to fulfill
all my other responsibilities as
Committee Chairman and the ranking
Republican and Democratic members of the
ethics committee issued a statement they
said the committee is aware of public
allegations that representative Devin
Nunes may have made unauthorized
disclosures of classified information in
violation of house rules law regulations
and other standards of conduct the
committee pursuant to rule 18 a is
investigating and gathering more
information regarding these allegations
so all of the leading Republicans from
Trump to Ryan have expressed confidence
in Nunes what's amazing about about all
of this is that I actually think
newton's is doing the right thing here I
said a while ago I thought that Newton
should recuse himself after there were
questions about whether he was working
for Trump mainly because it overshadows
the actual scandal here which is Susan
Rice unmasking Trump officials and then
disseminated
that information widely to the Obama
team does it mean that Devin Nunes did
something terribly wrong no it doesn't
mean that Devin Nunes did something
terribly wrong the headlines are just
not going to be good the question here
was basically would be better for Nunes
to stick it out through the house ethics
committee and muddy the waters or would
be better for him to step aside and
hands it over to people like Gowdy and
Conway and allow them to pursue the
leaks investigation about Susan Rice and
Mike Flynn clearly I think for Trump it
is better for Newton's to take the
bullet on this one and step to the side
so i think the devin nunes did make the
right call here don't pay attention to
everybody who's saying this is obvious
proof that he did something deeply wrong
that's not right the house rules command
it's not even it's not even a just a
possibility to natural command the house
rules say that if there is an allegation
brought against you have leaking
classified information they must
investigate they have to investigate and
they have to open the inquiry by law so
it's not like they found something
credible and then when afternoons they
were forced to by the rules of the
committee so don't pay attention it's a
bit of a nothing burger don't pay
attention to everybody who's making a
huge deal out of noon stepping away not
proof that he did anything wrong or that
he was specifically working for Trump I
thought that he should my feeling was
that after he went to the White House
and learned all the stuff he should have
updated the members of the House
Intelligence Committee before running
back to Trump's report it was that
second trip to the White House that
looked particularly bad and and I wish
he hadn't done that but I don't know
that he actually did anything wrong here
and I think it's premature to say that
he did okay in other news that surrounds
the surrounds Trump Trump has done an
interview with The New York Times and in
this interview with The New York Times
he is now saying that he wants to do a
great infrastructure plan and on that
side I will say we're going to have been
a tremendous Democrats apart so
basically is looking for a democrat
support for a trillion-dollar
infrastructure plan and there were
questions about whether a lot of this
money was going to come from public
private projects out here in Los Angeles
we have public private projects in
places like the grove and the americana
this is basically a lot of a lot of
stadiums are public private projects
places where people invest their private
dollars and those are matched by a
certain amount of government money still
not my favorite thing but better than
just pure public investment and I from
says he doesn't even want the public
private projects anymore because he can
borrow money more easily and he knows
what to do with your money better than
you know what to do with your money he
says we may take that trillion and we
may also in addition use public private
but we're talking about an investment of
a trillion dollar so he explicitly said
that it's not going to be 200 300
billion dollars of public money and the
rest private it will be a trillion
dollars of public money and he said the
reason for that is because he can borrow
money so cheap well this was exactly
what Steve Anand had been saying for a
while was going to be Trump's plan so
the idea that the abandoned influence
with the administration is over I don't
think that's right I also think that
it's not just fanon's idea Donald Trump
made his name in life building really
big things with other people's money
that's what he's done his entire life
build really big things with other
people's money he's not going to stop
doing that now that he has trillions of
dollars at his disposal and there are a
lot of people on the right who seem okay
with this sort of infrastructure
spending you weren't okay with it when
it was about when Obama was spending
eight hundred billion dollars on random
crap it was bad was called the stimulus
plan and we said it's a waste of money
this also is a waste of money the fact
is that everybody talks about the
interstate highway system is though it's
going to cost a trillion dollars to fix
up the interstate highway system it
doesn't cost a trillion dollars to fix
up the interstate highway system plus it
is worthwhile noting that states and
localities have an interest in
maintaining the interstate highway
system since it carries all sorts of
goods and products and services through
their towns one of the great myths by
the way of American politics is that the
Eisenhower interstate highway system
with some sort of magnificent creation
that never would have happened if it
hadn't been for the intervention of the
federal government it's just not true
people drove long before the 1950s this
was a car country going back to the
1920s the interstate highway system cost
a lot of money it drove right through
towns it destroyed a lot of businesses
if you ever see the movie Cars you know
the Pixar movie Cars remember the whole
movie is set in this little town called
Radiator Springs which is off of route
66 and as you recall route 66 is
basically abandoned well route 66 used
to be one of the thoroughfares of
American commerce Nat King Cole had a
whole song about get your kicks on route
66 route 66 is an actual thing what
happened is that the federal government
built the i-40 the i-40 bypass route 66
all of these people who'd spent their
life savings and all their time and
money putting roots down around route 66
all of them are left behind and
destroyed so when you talk about
Forgotten people that a lot of people
who are forgotten because
interstate highway system or whose
houses were completely bulldozed by the
interstate highway system the case i'm
making is not there shouldn't be an
interstate highway system if it states
have an interest in connecting their
state highway systems and most of this
should have been absorbed at the local
and state level so when people say we
need lots of we need lots of
infrastructure spending now because it
was so great back in the 50s it wasn't
that great back in the 50s it isn't that
great now and when Trump does this
routine what he really wants is to build
big spectacular things he doesn't
actually want to fix up the roads and
bridges that matter per se he just wants
to build big stuff so that he can stamp
the big t on it and then say that he
built something which is what a lot of
these folks wanted to Obama wanted to do
it obviously ft automate his name doing
this it's not good policy there's
another poll by the way as long as I'm
going to get all the bathroom news out
of the way it's beginning there's
there's another poll that's out today
that says that forty percent of Trump
supporters would back a single-payer
health care system which just
demonstrates what folks like me have
been saying all along the great damage
the Trump could do and he hasn't done it
yet but the great damage that it is
possible for him to do is the
soul-sucking of the Republican Party
into a big government Nationalist Party
as opposed to a small government
patriotic party which is not quite the
same thing well all of that said the big
story of the day is is we'll get to the
Republican counts in a second but the
big story of the day is what is going to
happen in Syria so if you've been
watching the pictures that are coming
out of Syria obviously they are
horrifying we talked about this a little
bit yesterday either they're all these
pictures of dead children who have been
gassed to death by the Bashar Assad
regime and that comes just a few days
after the Trump administration came out
and said Assad would remain in power I
said that's not a coincidence if it had
happened under Obama I would have said
the exact same thing I have a very
simple standard when it comes to what I
expect from my politicians and that is
you know your word matters and what you
say has credibility and it turns out
that in foreign policy particularly it
matters when you say things so from the
fact that trumps people said Assad will
stay in power then three days later he's
gassing children I don't think that's
any sort of major coincidence survivor
of a 2013 syria chemical attack he's on
CNN and he was talking about what he
thinks from should do if I mean just say
a few words directly to petrol if you
leave me the chance please mustard
mr. president please please in the name
of every woman and child and elder who
got killed by the Assad regime please
come in and help us don't make the same
mistake that President Obama did you
criticized the Obama for failing to
punish and act when Assad cross the red
line now it's the moment of truth now
you should show the world that those
days are over we can just keep living in
this unprecedented crimes against
humanity we just can't keep living like
this I would personally love to come to
the United States and meet you and tell
you my personal story you know I think
the media is happy to put this sort of
stuff on TV because they're saying you
know Trump should do something there
there are two questions here one whose
fault is all of this and to excuse me
what should President Trump do right now
those are the two big questions it's
pretty clear that this is Obama's fault
it's pretty clear this started under
Obama that it was Obama who is saying
for years and years and years that we
had disarmed the Assad regime he
proclaimed himself a massive political
genius for having drawn a red line then
backed away from the red line after
Bashar Assad used chemical weapons
against his own people and then he said
that he had disarmed Assad and left
Assad in power well as I continued to
gas folks John McCain correctly says
this is Obama's legacy he's obviously as
we all are appalled could I make two
points one this is a legacy of Barack
Obama the last time this happened Barack
Obama said they crossed a red line
called me and Lindsey Graham down on the
White House and we and did nothing you
know one thing worse than doing nothing
is saying you're going to do something
is the most powerful leader on earth and
and doing nothing so this is a legacy of
Barack Obama and it's been going on now
for the intervening four years so what
we need to do need to stop Bosher Asajj
planes from flying and we can do that
easily you have been bringing this issue
up to the forefront I know it's been a
great frustration for you I gotta go but
just very quickly our safe zone Miami
team against Barack Obama had an
opportunity to
to stop this and would have long ago and
he took a hike and that's a terrible
legacy okay and McCain is exactly right
and listen McCain is no friend of trumps
when he says this is not Obama you can
trust the senator mccain is exactly
right on this certainly is not obama but
that doesn't answer what we should do
now i'm gonna discuss that in just a
second but first i don't want to say
thank you to our advertisers over at sea
so so if you are obsessed with comedy or
if you finish the news of the day and
you just need a lap you need to go to
see so calm and use promo code been this
is the place for comedy you can stream
as much original comedy content as you
want for 399 a month they have all of
the the back episodes of SNL they have
all the back episodes of the british the
office and all of you have old episodes
of monty python it's just the one stop
shop for all of the comedy that you're
possibly going to need my wife and I you
see so all the time we've been
subscribing I believe of our of our own
volition at this point for several
months because right now if you go over
to see socom SE ESO and you sign up with
promo code Ben and check out yet one
month for free so you can try it out see
if you like it we signed it we kept
paying for because we really like see so
SE ESO calm right now you sign up for
one month for free and as I say they've
got all the old episodes of the old
comedies they've got all the the old
episodes of late-night-tv including the
new late-night TV and they have a bunch
of new shows that are really funny one
of them that we tend to watch is there's
one called harmon quest that's pretty
funny it's the guy who created community
which was one of our favorite shows when
that was on TV and it is basically a
Dungeons and Dragons take off harmon
quest worth watching and the end they
have tons of comedy so you're never
going to go unentertaining on a
weeknight a lot cheaper than a lot of
the competing streaming services
obviously and it has more comedy than
all of them combined so it's se ESO com
it's the one stop shop for comedy see so
calm and use that promo code been again
they have all the stand up from fallon
and they've stand up from louis ck who
is lucy Kate you know it's so funny I
disagree with Lucy can everything
politically but he is so funny he is so
good and all of his specials are on T so
calm so check that out SE ESO calm use
that promo code ben says they know that
we sent you and also so you get one
month for free so the question is what
exactly should the United States do in
Syria now that we've seen
these terrible images coming out of
Syria but for you to get the answer to
that you're going to have to actually
subscribe to the show so go today lee
weyer calm right now and you can get for
a subscription for eight dollars a month
and go over there and check it out now
you can also get an annual subscription
and when you do that you get a free
signed copy of the master work reasons
to vote Democrat a comprehensive guide
the most thorough book on Democratic
thinking ever created by Michael moles
huge bestseller he just got a big
contract from a book publisher picking
it up which makes me sick to my stomach
daily wire.com to check that I become a
subscriber or an annual subscriber if
you become an annual subscriber you
still get a free signed copy if you just
want to listen to the rest of the show
later then go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud by the way I forgot if you're
a subscriber then make sure that you
subscribe now because tomorrow's mail
bags if you have questions we can answer
all your life's questions in the mailbag
but only if you're a subscriber if you
just want to listen itunes or soundcloud
leave us a review we always appreciate
it we are the most popular conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you